but now let's go move back to the
Conservatives a couple of weeks ago at
Boris Johnson reshuffled his ministerial
team and one of the people he sacked
from government was the Transport
Minister Tanner's garni now she hasn't
spoken publicly since that sacking she
joins us now in the studio thanks very
much for being with us this morning just
talk us through what happened when the
news was broken - that you were sacked
well politics has no rhyme and reason
and it's not like any other business job
that you you do and the the reshuffle
was being covered on the news quite a
bit and when I knew I was speaking to
the prime minister quite early in the
morning I I think I knew that the gig
was up and it's Paul it sort of played
out in public which is slightly
different to any other any of the job
that you can do you need the gig was up
I guess when you're called to his office
in the House of Commons it was it was a
telephone conversation yeah but it was
it was quite early on in in the morning
so I had a feeling that maybe something
was up but look you know you are you
it's a huge privilege being a minister
and it's absolutely right that the Prime
Minister gets to choose who serves in
government and I had a fantastic
experience and I got very lucky with the
portfolio that I got to got to manage
but politics is very strange things move
on very fast so when the news breaks and
your your life is sort of all your
pictures on TV for a couple of hours
your phone is buzzing but then the next
thing happens and all of a sudden the
story moves on quite quickly how does
that feel is it you relieved that
story's moved on or you bit sad that
your phone's not going I'm almost
relieved the story because early in the
morning you're getting thousands of
messages about what's going on and then
later on you're getting thousands of
messages about him that it's resignation
but look it's absolutely right or the
Prime Minister get to choose who who
serves in his government so what did he
say to you on the phone then well you
know talked about my worker and pleased
that turned the work that I did was
recognised I was very lucky that I was
able to do some groundbreaking pieces of
work within transport we were able to
put together the first public transport
accessibility package which means that
we're the only country in the world
that's aligned ourselves to the UN goals
to ensure that all of our public
transport system is accessible to people
with disabilities did he
to give you a reason respect to the
Prime Minister doesn't have to give a
reason and I think that is the way that
it should be about no there was there
wasn't a reason but look I wasn't really
expecting one and not as the Prime
Minister have to give a reason either
manoa honestly were high profile backer
of Jeremy Hunt during the leadership
campaign do you think there's any truth
in the feeling that some may have that
this is a government that prizes loyalty
above all last I think closely to the
job and I think if you do a stellar job
that it's not that noted to the job is
it that we're talking about its loyalty
to the leadership two personalities two
characters I think politics just moves
on so fast if that just seen as old
history look I did support Jeremy and I
thought it was important that brexit
ears like myself who campaigned for
brexit supported Jeremy the party had
been in a bind for quite a while and it
was important for a number of us to
ensure that both candidates had backers
from both form or spectrums of brexit I
was also conflicted and whilst the
leadership campaign was going on I was
undertaking the delivery of a hs2 bill
through the house and I didn't want to
be conflicted while delivering that
piece of legislation but it's really
it's old news what's what's great is
that we've got a prime minister that's
brought the party together and also
brought the country together we've got a
fantastic majority and we're delivering
a warn nation conservative agenda it
sounds like you're angling for a return
it is a pleasure to be asked to to serve
in government but I was only on the back
benches for a couple of years I'm
looking forward to cracking on with some
of the campaign's that I set up there
one last question before we move on and
what did you do after you got the news
we saw the picture of Andrea LED assume
you know treating high team too few
bottles of wine was it well the peculiar
thing is you you're you know when when
you when you get the news it's very fast
and also you don't want to be in the way
of the new ministers arriving so you
sort of pack up immediately and you you
leave quite quickly and at the same time
you're saying goodbye to your the staff
in the department and you're trying to
provide them with some leadership as
well because did they they were getting
a bit emotional when I was on on the way
out I was hoping that my phone was going
to run out of battery because the
messages are coming in so thinking fast
and it obviously wasn't in them I went
home and we had curry for lunch
and just to move on to tell me other
stories around today and so Philip
Ruttman the most senior official in the
Home Office has quit suing the
government of a constructive dismissal
in your experience what's the
government's relationship like with the
civil servants is there a problem there
look look in my experience wouldn't a
public transport the were occasions when
there were tensions because we are
undertaking a fantastic agenda of
delivering the people's priorities and
we had as well as delivering within
transport we had the extra items of work
to do around preparing for a new
relationship with Europe this is a
fantastic agenda delivering on the
people's priorities Why should there be
any conflict with the civil service
we're working at a very very progressive
pace of my experience of progressive
means fast or fast but a moment you know
my experience of working with pretty is
that she is incredibly determined she
provides strong leadership and she's
delivering some very important aspects
of our policy the items that we promise
that the election we must not forget
just recently that Preeti Patel
announced the points based immigration
system and also new funding for policing
as well these are two very important and
heavy items of work that she has
delivered I do think it's curious that
if you're providing leadership if you're
determined working at a fantastic pace
that within men that is seen as a
fantastic skill and for women sometimes
it's seen as challenging what so you
think some of the coverage has been a
bit success we don't know you know she's
doing a fantastic job my constituents
are pleased that we've delivered on what
we promised on the points-based
immigration and also that Pretty's
delivered on on policing the forum - now
you were a Transport Minister and this
week a court ruled that building a third
runway at Heathrow would be illegal the
government said it was going to accept
the decision it wasn't going to
challenge it now of course
Boris Johnson famously said he was going
to lie down in front of the bulldozers
to stop it from happening
do you think the government was quietly
relieved I can't speak on behalf of
government aim I'm no longer a minister
but I am very disappointed in the
decision that was taken by the ruling we
are you know we are president presenting
ourselves as global Britain Heathrow and
all aviation is incredibly key to that
and I'm absolutely disappointed if you
look at the actual judgment it did
misty appeals on air quality and noise
but has focused on a component that
maybe not all advice was taken to deal
with our target for zero emissions and
assume that could be because the advice
was taken baby before April 2019 when we
were focused on reducing emissions by
80% not by a hundred percent so it seems
quite technical
Heathrow said that they would challenge
the decision that was taken and and as
they should know 40% of our a trade
outside Europe they said it's a private
enterprise and he said we'll take that
going forward I think that we can be
compatible with our growth and
infrastructure and dealing with our
targets on zero emissions as well and
you're clearly fully behind the idea of
this third runway I mean I know that
you're especially specialty was kind of
maritime when you were in the transport
but just from your experience working
there did you get a sense that Boris
Johnson was fully behind a third runway
we will there wasn't you within the
department you just focus on what you
need to deliver and we carried on
delivering that when I was the haterz to
minister and I took into account with
all MPs you might Minister sort there
sure but look we I think what we need to
do is ensure that we can make it
compatible that we can have a growth in
aviation and manage our emissions - if I
just reflect on the work that I did in
maritime we had a huge challenge with
the growth in maritime and I wanted to
make sure that any decision we take in
the UK didn't undermine the maritime
sector in the UK so we did two things
when I first became a minister in 2018 I
worked with the International Maritime
Organization to deliver a global
objective to reducing greenhouse gas
emissions from all shipping and then we
had our own national strategy as well in
the UK so where the flights take off or
into Heathrow that you know doesn't
really account to Calibri emissions
because they'll be taking place
elsewhere every day a decision is
delayed we're losing business to another
out Airport elsewhere now well we've got
you on keen to talk to you about what's
happening in Afghanistan something I
know that you've been following quite
closely at the US and the Taliban
signing that historic peace deal is this
good news or should we be worried of
course any way that we can deliver peace
in Afghanistan is good news but I am
anxious about what this actually means
assigning a peace deal with the Taliban
isn't signing a pistol with the
government of Afghanistan we've already
seen elections that took place last
September and there is tensions between
President Ghani and Abdullah Abdullah
chief executive who didn't did not win
that election even irshaf garni won by
50% 51 percent of the vote the Taliban
don't represent the government and the
Taliban most definitely do not represent
all Afghan people within this deal if
you unpack it there is a release of over
5,000 prisoners and people might think
this is such a long distance from home
what does it matter to us but it matters
for two particular reasons security in
Afghanistan impacts us here Afghanistan
is the largest producer of opium and
most of that opium is produced in
Taliban held territory and Taliban has
got links to al-qaeda to die and Al
nusra front and all these Islamist
ideologists do you have an impact on how
young people are groomed in the UK to
become extremists as well do you think
the US might have been a bit tubes but
wooed by the idea of signing this peace
deal without actually looking at what
might being compromised they've spent
nearly two decades in the country I
assume that they wanted to to leave and
you know put some of the pressure back
on and the Afghans themselves to deliver
peace in the area but it's not as smooth
as what I'm reading in the papers that
having a peace deal with the Taliban is
a peace deal with the Afghan people or
the Afghan government and what do you
think the UK government should do I
think we need to we need to still
continue to play incredible close
attention to the country and the region
it isn't over yet at all and my
experience of working in Afghanistan and
working with Afghan parliamentarians in
particular we have had - well the Afghan
women have had to move mountains to be
recognized as equal citizens in some
areas in Afghanistan and the prospect
that this could all go back to square
one where we've been were flogged in
public or even executed we were four you
know flogged for showing in an
interesting if the work wearing the full
veil then they carve they weren't
allowed to go to school and participate
outside of home we cannot go back to a
system where they are treated so
abhorrently not you think that might
happen
well the the Afghan women are concerned
and I'm concerned for them as well there
was a there was a
Afghan parliamentarian who was involved
in the negotiations and she'd wanted to
be a doctor in early life it wasn't
allowed to go to school and when she
became a parliamentarian the Taliban you
know tried to attack her and a number of
occasions so I have a huge anxiety to to
try and believe that the a peace deal
with the Taliban will deliver any sort
of peace for Afghan women you will
always be the first ever Muslim woman to
serve as a minister how concerned are
you about the inquiry into Islamophobia
in the Conservative Party
I'm the first female Muslim MP to speak
at the despatch-box and that happened
back in 2018 which was also the year
that we celebrate celebrating the
centenary of women getting the vote so
it was sort of poignant I you know we we
the the inquiry are you yes I've got
full confidence that the Prime Minister
and the new chairman will continue to
undertake this inquiry I had a meeting
with number 10 just a few weeks ago to
say that we need to crack on with this
and get it done when is it can happen
then I don't have those details to
handle I'm not responsible for the
inquiries right it's quite simple to set
up though isn't it well the inquiry has
to take in to account processes and
cases that are brought forward I want to
make sure the inquiry it is done that
the conclusions are out there that when
people fall below the threshold that
what we accept is acceptable on all
forms of racism and abuse that they're
dealt with quickly and then removed as
well okay thank you very much Corrine
the show at Ana's Ghani I'm sitting
there thank you